so here are this year's nominees for  achievement in makeup Barney's Version  Adrian Moreau the way back Edward F  Enrique's Gregory funk and Yolanda to  sing the wolf man Rick Baker and Dave  Elsie that's gross  and the Oscar goes to the wolf man Rick  Baker and Dave Elfie  [Music]  this is the seventh Academy Award and  twelfth nomination for Rick Baker the  first Oscar and second nomination for  Dave LC  oh man I'm smiling so big my face hurts  it's like uh I just want to thank my  beautiful wife Silvia for knowing me so  well and for being so right I'm so glad  I listened to you honey go David Kirk II  um thank you to Benicio del Toro to  Anthony Hopkins also the Universal  Studios for their legacy of horror  monsters that we love so much thank you  to our entire crew and thank you to my  beautiful wife Lou I love you it was  always my ambition to lose an Oscar one  day to Rick Baker this is better thank  you  [Applause]